[Music]
you may remember that Brittany got her
first to be ma nomination for her first
hit maybe one more time but her career
began long before that JC the Mickey
Mouse Club 25 years ago we're coming up
on that reunion yes there you know
everybody's so much about everybody
getting back together or having reboots
could it ever happen it was a really
good time and it was a great time it was
probably one of the most special times
in my life as a Mickey Mouse Club would
you ever think about getting everybody
back together again
um me well they would have to plan I
would definitely show up I would dick oh
definitely he first met Brittany in 1999
she talked all about getting that Mickey
Mouse Club role when she was just 12
years old after that show that's when I
realized I had a major lefty music oh
how can you say so probably like when
I'm on stage I'm a different person like
I totally explode and I have attitude
and but when I come off the stage I'm
just so like this entertainment business
has not affected me really at all I'm
still the same Brittany totally
[Music]
from photoshoots to award shows we've
been with Britney through all of her ups
and downs and right now is definitely
enough Britney's Las Vegas residency
brought in 140 million and she just
launched her piece of meat or last
Thursday my show is a workout in itself
so it kind of keeps you really strong
are you like really careful about what
you eat sometimes I'm like I just want a
hamburger but when I'm in real work mode
I want very clean I like just clean
chicken or veggies like that's it my
stomach is so sensitive I have a steak
I'll be since like stick for three days
you're kidding me and then what about
the burger where does the burger do to
any burgers line there's you know could
I have the small burgers from McDonald's
the happy milk we're just so happy that
[Music]